FATHER IN THE STUDIO.
>> Sean: ANYTHING FOR RATINGS.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY," BREAKING
ONLY MOMENTS AGO FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," MAJOR NEW
DEVELOPMENT IN JOHN DURHAM'S
INVESTIGATION INTO THE ORIGINS
OF THE RUSSIA PROBE, THIS IS
HUGE.
IF YOUR NAME IS BRENNAN,
CLAPPER, OR COMEY, YOU MAY WANT
TO LAWYER UP BECAUSE HE'S
SEEKING INTERVIEWS WITH TOP CIA
OFFICERS.
INVESTIGATION INTO THE
INVESTIGATORS IS GOING TO BE
ALL-ENCOMPASSING LIKE WE HAVE
BEEN TELLING YOU, IT WILL LIKELY
NOW SPREAD ACROSS CONTINENTS.
PAY ATTENTION TO ITALY,
GREAT BRITAIN, AND AUSTRALIA.
ACCORDING TO THE TIMES, CIA
DIRECTOR GINA HASKELL IS
INSTRUCTING HER AGENCY TO FULLY
COOPERATE AND THEY WILL.
FROM THE DIRTY DOSSIER TO THE
RAMP AT THAT SPYING AGAINST
TRUMP ASSOCIATES AND THE LEAKING
OF SENSITIVE MATERIAL TO RIG AN
ELECTION, THE SINGLE BIGGEST
ABUSE OF POWER SCANDAL IN
AMERICAN HISTORY, THE TRUTH IS
NOW BEING COVERED.
THE BOOMERANG OF ALL BOOMERANGS
OF JUSTICE IS IN FULL SWING AND
HIGH-RANKING FORMER BUREAUCRATS,
THEY ARE IN DEEP TROUBLE TONIGH
TONIGHT.
THERE'S NO STOPPING THIS TRAIN.
DEMOCRATS AND THEIR FRIENDS IN
THE MEDIA ARE STILL FIXATED ON
ONE ISSUE AND ONE ONLY -- RAGED
PSYCHOSIS AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
AS WE SPEAK, ONCE AGAIN
APOPLECTIC.
THIS IS THE MOST AMAZING SET UP
YOU WILL EVER SEEK HIM A
BRAND-NEW INTERVIEW CLIP BETWEEN
THE PRESIDENT AND ABCs GEORGE
STEPHANOPOULOS, TAKE A LOOK.
>> RUSSIA, CHINA, IF SOMEONE
ELSE OFFERS INFORMATION, SHOULD
THEY ACCEPT IT OR CALL THE FBI?
>> I THINK THEY DO BOTH, YOU
MIGHT WANT TO LISTEN, THERE'S
NOTHING WRONG WITH LISTENING.
IF SOMEBODY CALLED FROM A
COUNTRY -- NORWAY -- WE HAVE
INFORMATION ON YOUR OPPONENT, I
THINK I WOULD WANT TO HEAR IT.
>> YOU WANT THAT KIND OF
INTERFERENCE IN OUR ELECTIONS?
>> IS NOT INTERFERENCE, THEY
HAVE INFORMATION.
I THINK I WOULD TAKE IT, IF
THERE WAS SOMETHING WRONG I
WOULD GO TO THE FBI.
>> Sean: THIS IS WHAT'S
FASCINATING, YOU MIGHT WANT TO
LISTEN.
LISTENING IS MUCH DIFFERENT THAN
LYING, SPYING, AND PAYING FOR
RUSSIAN LIES AND SPREADING IT
THROUGH DEEP STATE OPERATIVES
AND USING IT AS A BASIS FOR A
FISA WARRANT.
MIGHT WANT TO LISTEN AND THEN
REPORTED TO THE FBI, WHY ARE
THEY NOT OUTRAGED ABOUT HILLARY
PAYING FOR RUSSIAN LIES,
DISINFORMATION, COMEY GENEROUSLY
USING THE UNVERIFIABLE DATA FROM
RUSSIA TO SPY ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND GET A FISA WARRANT.
THIS WILL ALL GET ANOTHER ROUND
OF FAKE, PHONY, MORAL SELECTIVE
OUTRAGE OVER THAT INTERVIEW BUT
IT'S A PERFECT SET UP BECAUSE IF
THEY ARE OUTRAGED ABOUT THAT AND
HOW CAN YOU NOT BE OUTRAGED OVER
WHAT I JUST SAID?
THAT'S ALL TO BE EXPECTED.
THE MEDIA MOB WILL FALL RIGHT
INTO HIS TRAP BREATHLESSLY
SPEWING FAKE, PHONY OUTRAGE OVER
A NONSTORY FOR DAYS, WE WILL BE
SHOWING YOU THE TAPE THIS TIME
TOMORROW NIGHT IGNORING THE REAL
ABUSE OF POWER THAT TOOK PLACE
IN 2016 AND THE REAL RUSSIAN
DOSSIER THAT WAS BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR AND USES A BASIS TO SPY ON
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
MORE PROOF IF YOU NEEDED IT THE
MEDIA MOB IS NOTHING MORE THAN
AN EXTENSION OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE BUT ONLY
IF IT'S TRUMP, NOT HILLARY, THEY
ARE WORRIED ABOUT UNDERLYING
CRIMES BUT ONLY IF IT'S TRUMP,
NOT HILLARY, THEY ARE WORRIED
ABOUT BELIEVING, BUT ONLY IF IT
BLUDGEONS TRUMP, NOT WITH THE
GOVERNOR OF VIRGINIA OVER
SERIOUS SEX ALLEGATIONS, TODAY
THEY TURNED CAPITOL HILL INTO
THE TWILIGHT ZONE.
THE KNOWN LIAR COWARDLY
ADAM SCHIFF, FOUR HOURS FREE, HE
HELD ANOTHER HEARING ABOUT HIS
FAVORITE FANTASY, THE RUSSIA
HOAX, THE ONLY GUY CAUGHT
COLLUDING ON TAPE WITH THE
RUSSIANS.
FOUR PREVIOUS INVESTIGATIONS ALL
CONCLUDING POLLUTION IS A LIE
AND A MYTH AND UNPROVABLE BUT
THAT DOESN'T MATTER BECAUSE HE
IS NOTHING MORE THAN A LIAR AND
A CON ARTISTS, THAT'S WHAT HE
DOESN'T COME ON THE SHOW, HIS
SOLE MISSION IS TO SMEAR
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THAT'S WHY THE
HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE CHAIR HELD
ANOTHER SHAM HEARING TODAY ON
WHAT HE CALLED DISTURBING
FINDINGS, VOLUME 1 OF THE
MUELLER REPORT, THE SAME VOLUME
THAT TOTALLY CLEAR TRUMP AND HIS
ENTIRE CAMPAIGN, IT SAID "THE
INVESTIGATION DID NOT ESTABLISH"
MR. SCHIFF, WHAT PART DON'T YOU
UNDERSTAND "THAT MEMBERS OF THE
CAMPAIGN CONSPIRED OR INTERFERED
WITH THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT."
THE ONLY ONE THAT PAID FOR
RUSSIAN LIES IS YOUR CANDIDATE,
HILLARY.
675 DAYS, 2800 SUBPOENAS, 500
SEARCH WARRANTS, 500 WITNESSES,
230 ORDERS FOR COMMUNICATION
RECORDS, 19 HYPERPARTISAN
ANTI-TRUMP INVESTIGATORS AND ALL
DEMOCRATIC DONORS, EVEN
HILLARY CLINTON'S ATTORNEY, THE
WORST ATTORNEY --
ANDREW WEISSMANN ON THE FACE OF
THE EARTH, OVER $25 MILLION
SPENT AND EVEN MUELLER'S TEAM
FOUND NO COLLUSION.
THEY WERE ONLY ABLE TO PRODUCE A
400 SOME ODD PAGE DOCUMENT
FILLED WITH SMEARS, INSINUATION
AND EVEN TOOK AN EDITED TAPE OF
THE TRUMP ATTORNEY, DOWD, OUT OF
CONTEXT, A HEAVILY EDITED
VOICE MAIL TO MAKE ATTORNEY
JOHN DOWD LOOK BAD.
TOTAL MISCHARACTERIZATION OF
PAUL MANAFORT'S BUSINESS
ASSOCIATE, THEY TOTALLY ADMITTED
TO FUSION GPS WAS COMPLICIT IN
PAYING FOR RUSSIAN LIES AND
PROPAGANDA, THEY HIRED
CHRISTOPHER STEELE ON BEHALF OF
HILLARY CLINTON, THAT SOME OF
THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG AND HOW
COULD THEY NOT INVESTIGATE THE
PHONY RUSSIAN DOSSIER IF YOU'RE
INVESTIGATING RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE IN 2016?
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES PROBABLY
DELIVERED THE BEST SPEECH OF HIS
CAREER, HE WILL JOIN US IN A
MINUTE -- WATCH THIS.
>> EVENTUALLY THE DEMOCRATS
BECAME CONVINCED THAT THE
MUELLER REPORT WOULD FINALLY RID
THEM OF THEIR SINISTER PRESIDENT
WHO HAD THE AUDACITY TO DEFEAT
HILLARY CLINTON.
THE DEMOCRATS ASSEMBLED US TODAY
TO ANALYZE THE SHODDY POLITICAL
HIT PIECE KNOWN AS THE MUELLER
REPORT.
IT'S WRITTEN IN THE SAME SPIRIT
IN THE SAME PURPOSE AS THE
STEELE DOSSIER WHICH WAS ONCE
CHAMPIONED BY THE DEMOCRATS ON
THIS COMMITTEE BUT WHICH THEY
BARELY MENTIONED AFTER IT WAS
EXPOSED AS ANOTHER DEMOCRAT
CREATED HOAX.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR THE DEMOCRATS,
THE MUELLER DOSSIER DEBUNKED
THEIR CONSPIRACY THEORIES OR
THEY DIDN'T FIND IT WORTH
DISCUSSING.
>> Sean: COMING UP, IT'S
LIKELY AUTHOR DEVELOPED TRUMP
PATER ANDREW WEISSMANN, THE
CAREER PROSECUTOR.
HE'S THE PITBULL AS LABELED BY
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," HE
ATTENDED THE 2016 VICTORY PARTY
FOR MIKE HILLARY.
HIS TRACK RECORD IS HORRIFIC,
SIDNEY POWELL'S BOOK JUST IS A
BRUTAL TAKEDOWN DETAILING
WEISSMANN AND HIS NOTORIOUS
WITHHOLDING OF INFORMATION, HE
SENT MERRILL EXECUTIVES TO
PRISON FOR A YEAR, HE GOT
OVERTURNED 9-0.
WHAT AN ACHIEVEMENT BY THE
SUPREME COURT.
THOUSANDS OF ACCOUNTING
EMPLOYEES LOST THEIR JOBS
BECAUSE OF WEISSMANN AND TONIGHT
WE CAN REPORT THAT HIS BIGGEST
CRITIC SIDNEY POWELL HAS NOW
BEEN HIRED TO REPRESENT TENANT
GENERAL MICHAEL FLYNN, THAT'S
THE LEGAL TEAM RESPONSIBLE FOR
HIS GUILTY PLEA.
POWELL 16 MONTHS AGO BLASTED THE
WITCH HUNT HE'S NOW TAKING OVER.
NO WORD IF HE PLANS TO WITHDRAW.
A CHANGE OF COURSE LOOKS
IMMINENT, HE SAID 16 MONTHS AGO
HE SHOULD WITHDRAW THAT PLEA, I
AGREE ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF
WHAT THE GOVERNMENT DID TO A 33
YEAR RETIRED GENERAL, A WAR HERO
WHO SERVED THIS COUNTRY WITH
HONOR AND DISTINCTION.
REMEMBER, FLYNN WAS ILLEGALLY
UNMASKED, THEY LEAKED RAW
INTELLIGENCE ON HIM AND REMEMBER
AFTER TRUMP WAS SWORN IN, DAY
FOUR OF HIS ADMINISTRATION, HE
SENT AGENTS TO THE WHITE HOUSE
TO SET A PERJURY TRAP, THEY
ALREADY LISTEN TO THE TAPE AFTER
THE DEPUTY FBI DIRECTOR SAID
THAT YOU DON'T NEED A LAWYER.
HE BRAGS ABOUT SETTING UP A 33
YEAR VETERAN, THIS IS A NATIONAL
DISGRACE.
>> YOU LOOK AT THIS WHITE HOUSE
NOW IT'S HARD TO IMAGINE TWO FBI
AGENTS ENDING UP IN THE SAME
ROOM, HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
>> I SENT THEM.
[LAUGHTER]
SOMETHING I PROBABLY WOULDN'T
HAVE DONE OR GOTTEN AWAY WITH IN
A MORE ORGANIZED INVESTIGATION,
AND MORE ORGANIZED
ADMINISTRATION, IN THE
GEORGE W. BUSH ADMINISTRATION OR
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AND IN
BOTH OF THOSE ADMINISTRATIONS
THERE WAS PROCESS.
THE FBI WANTED TO SENT AGENTS
INTO THE WHITE HOUSE ITSELF TO
INTERVIEW A SENIOR OFFICIAL, YOU
WOULD WORK THROUGH THE
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL AND THERE
WOULD BE DISCUSSIONS AND
APPROVALS AND I THOUGHT IT'S
EARLY ENOUGH, LET'S SEND A
COUPLE GUYS OVER.
>> Sean: LAUGHING ABOUT TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF A WAR HERO, YOU
AREN'T THE SUPER PATRIOT YOU
CLAIM TO BE, YOU SEEM TO BE
NOTHING BUT A CORRUPT CAREER
BUREAUCRATS, YOU THINK YOU ARE
UNTOUCHABLE.
SADLY YOU ARE WHAT JOE DIGENOVA
DESCRIBED -- I DON'T EVEN WANT
TO SAY IT BECAUSE IT MAKES ME
MAD IS KNOWING MOST OF MY FAMILY
SERVED IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
I HAVE NEWS FOR THE EVER SO
PIOUS KING OF THE DEEP STATE,
JUSTICE IS COMING YOUR WAY AND I
PREDICT TONIGHT YOU WILL BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE FOR COMMITTING YOUR
FRAUD, YOUR PREMEDITATED FRAUD
ON A FISA COURT AND NOT SET UP
YOU ARE BRAGGING ABOUT WILL BE
YOUR LEGACY.